when did you get to the point where you
realized we don't need ad teaching jobs
anymore we want to quit teaching for me
became
suffocating why don't they teach kids
about money in schools the whole system
is set up it's a control system actually
schools do lack very much i thought i
was stupid at school because it was like
if you don't do well in your exams then
you're not very smart you won't go very
far do you know what you're doing now or
helping others get financially free i
would love to go back and teach again
with somebody who really benefit from
what i'm teaching we've sold over the
last three and a half years 53 years
it's generated 240 000 pounds worth of
income showing other people that
actually somebody without any property
background can actually be successful
there are all sorts of ways of making
money but just get started
congratulations on your massive success
in property thank you you guys are
background as teachers when did you get
to the point where you realized we don't
need our teaching jobs anymore we want
to quit for me it was about two years
ago originally um and i did have my
notice in from teaching and then covert
hit yeah and then it was a case of
i think i'd better go back and the
school wanted me back so i went back oh
did you i did yeah i did another two
years and now i have handed my notice in
and i finished so now it's like you're
done done now i'm done forever forever
what about you jeremy how long have you
been quit it was always a means to an
end to teaching for me i i always knew
it
properly is all it's something that's
been burning since i can remember i went
to university because my mum
really wanted me to go i went into
teaching because
everybody else seemed to be going into
teaching
and at that time i had
no
no real science behind me as far as
property goes
so
i taught and there's elements of it i
really enjoyed and you're very good at
it you're very good teacher in fact when
i first met you
and you were at the deal finding
extravaganza and doing deals i remember
that you once you booked your viewings
and you'd had your success naturally
you'd then go and find someone that's
struggling and i remember thinking
i want these guys to not only be become
property millionaires and absolutely
kill it but i want them to help me
down the line at giving back and that's
exactly what's happening now
it's really interesting to say that
because we both talk about this and you
become teachers for a reason it's a buzz
yeah it's actually buzz but teaching for
me became
uh it was almost suffocating that it was
the system yeah that was the suffocation
and totally you're expected to go up the
ranks and they take more on and whatever
why don't they teach kids about money in
schools
that is a really really good question um
i've certainly realized that now since
i've started on this route that actually
schools do lack very much and people
still believe family that they need to
educate themselves get a job
and then retire and i think i was stupid
at school because it was like if you
don't do well in your exams then you're
not very smart you won't go very far
there's only one teacher mrs hay smith
that used to follow me around the school
saying you're going to be so successful
like she saw the fire but most people
don't see the fire no but isn't that
true about all sorts you know you can be
gifted and talented at sports or you can
be gifted and talented a stage or art or
whatever and i remember kids coming up
to me all right when we've left school
yeah so i'm thick and they labeled
themselves yeah as not successful
because they couldn't pass
gcses or a-levels or they were dyslexic
and you know
the whole system is set up and i
understand why it is it's a control
system you know it's also for me in
education it was all about successful
failure
rather than okay well done
or do you know what you haven't quite
got that right how could you do it
differently yeah and actually really but
and in property that's one of the
biggest things that we've we've learned
you know
we talked about that portfolio that you
know we we talked about before and
that was nip and tuck nip and tuck lip
and tuck for 12 months on your first
property set when you packaged something
and sold it how much did you make profit
i can remember the very first property
and you know
we brought in three and a half thousand
pounds okay or it generated three and a
half thousand pounds fell through the
next day
sold it again
for four thousand pounds this time
and that ended up falling through oh
geez what was it the vendor went to
thailand and we never got the vendor
sorry the the buyer went to um yeah i
went to went to thailand and you've
never seen him again no no did you know
that that went through he disappeared
you know the sale fell through in the
end but did you get the money though
yeah absolutely paid you four grand then
went to thailand and you never heard
from him again yeah and under the terms
and conditions this was like three four
five months
down the line but cut a long story short
so that's not the most bizarre thing
about that property
the vendor
then said right i've had it with
investors i'm going to put it on the
market i'm going to do an online agent
one of the one of the online agents cut
long story short 10 months he came back
to me said
i still can't shift this property and
it's a five bedroom hmo with grandfather
rights and in our area grandfather
rights are worth a fortune and we ended
up getting that property on a lease
purchase agreement oh
that was our first one wasn't it yeah so
you got it on a purchase lease option
agreement yep we agreed a price in four
years so we didn't have the option we
knew that that was going to be right and
if you bought it now then we're just
about to go through look at investor
finance on that one it's now valued at
150 when we purchased at 92. oh my
goodness so in your first lease option
agreement that's 60 000 pounds yep
uplift yeah and why is it cash flowing
as well it cash flows really well sort
of rents the turnovers to about 2-3
something like that so it probably earns
us cash flow eleven hundred quid a month
that's incredible what a deal you've
done a lot of deals though and you've
what about that portfolio um your
packages and salt how much profit did
you make on that
that actually uh generated 65 000 pounds
on on that one what would you even be
thinking about your teacher's job when
you just sold a dealer made 65 grand
it was really early days i think and it
was almost a disbelief wasn't it
you went to you went to grimsby it
stayed in an airbnb
met the owner of the airbnb because
you'd tell you'd broken yeah and he said
you told him that you were a property
investor because that's what you have to
do some chat told me on the academy i
should be saying that yeah so and then
you phoned me and said this guy wants me
to sell a house one of his houses
and then by the end of the weekend after
he had breakfast it was he's got 17
houses he wants me to sell what we're
going to do
i wanted to elevate myself so i took him
to weatherspoons
so that was it you came back with his
portfolio so of 17 properties to sell
yeah
and it was very early days wasn't it
yeah and it's a classic case so that's
where you've done it have you mostly
been selling deals or have you been
buying deals
selling deals to start with very much
so you took us on the first mentor
session and you know you're looking at
talking to me about net worth do you
know we had a massive negative net worth
we'd both come out of different
marriages
and you know we were
really struggling we'd given up homes
and you know we were renting
and actually
that starting that whole process was was
really tough because we needed yeah i i
didn't even know what a deal source it
was until the first session we had in
birmingham and you said i've just looked
at your figures yeah you need to be deal
sources you didn't say it with a snicker
[Laughter]
i was like damn you broke
that was it yeah i remember it was in
hell what what was your net worth was it
like minus something minus thousands and
when i took let's talk to mentor i don't
know i'm skipping around a little bit
but when people come and say ah twelve
thousand pounds academy has someone else
they don't see the value in that and i
didn't at that time i i really did i
could only see 12 000 pounds as 12 000
pounds and
it
i know we'd mentioned at that starting
point and i hear people starting off on
the academy so now as long as i make
back what i've put into it and that's
such a broke mindset which i had i'm not
being disrespectful to other people but
i was there as well at that starting
point so to your question do you know we
carry on we we've sold over um the last
three and a bit years 53 deals 54 deals
now
you know and it's it's generated 240 000
pounds worth of income and you know
we've loved every second of it but for
me i've always wanted to be putting back
into property i love it and it comes
from my grandfather and i i just it's
passive income yeah deal sourcing is
active income correct and even
if you get to a stage where you've
systemized it and processed it enough so
we only work on a bespoke service now
and you know
sales didn't come naturally to me i had
to work flipping hard at getting selling
off a list and when i watch you sell
live in front of an audience i think i'd
take my hat off to you do you know and
you talk about grant own cell be sold
and yeah the closes almanac and all the
rest i've listened and listened and i've
got better i came from a network
marketing business but i think teachers
find sales naturally difficult yeah oh
very yeah very very difficult and i
don't understand why because it is such
a
you are so open with communication and
talking to parents talking to children
talking to colleagues and it is very
very bizarre a different world though
it's a completely different world and
it's been such an eye-opening i'll tell
you something interesting about me when
i was deciding what school with my wife
to send my kids to
this sounds really bad but when i go
into a school it makes me feel ill
really i just need to get out yeah
and i kind of feel like i can't believe
i'm sending my kids like to a prison
where if i'm there for five minutes i'm
just like i stopped being rude and
stopped i stopped being i'm just like it
just reminds me of when i was at school
and i want to get out
such a strange it's such a strange thing
i'm sure the problems with me somewhere
oh it's an emotional response
and that's really sad yeah and
do you know what you're doing now of
helping others get financially free you
know i said to gene i would love to go
back and teach again but with somebody
who really wants and would benefit from
what i'm teaching and don't get me wrong
i go into schools i've been into schools
enough and i've taught financial
literacy and stuff
in schools in london and that's
different because i'm then i'm loving it
but when i was just going around and
they were showing me the different
classrooms i was just like hating it and
we just built a school you know in
uganda i'm going in in about six weeks
so i am massively for education but i
just think there's something about the
culture of
state schools
well you said that was the question of
what why don't they teach it in schools
and you know
i think i realized i was part of a
system that you know one is archaic do
you know and i think
and i'm not i'm not political but you
know i understand that everybody needs a
basic form of education and actually
developed communities and economies you
you need to have educated people and
some people thrive in that i'm not i'm
not knocking those people
and and my daughter so she's doing a
maths degree at the moment she said dad
i know you're doing property but you
know i don't want to run a business
you don't have to run a business if you
want to carry on being employed just
make your money work for you and
actually learn what passive income is
and actually learn what an asset is you
know you've been very successful in
property what was it that made you want
to come back
and help the academy as a mentor it's
the sharing isn't it the sharing of
information and knowledge and
i think i've come from a very
traditional background of going through
education
learning how to be teacher going and
being a teacher for 28 years and it's
been a very very traditional route i
can't believe tony
i know and i think i think for me it's
about
showing other people that actually
somebody from a very very traditional
background without any property
background can actually be successful in
that field and that's really massive and
i think that's how i want my kids to see
me is you know my mum's gone mad what's
she doing now
but actually to show them that there is
a very very different way and hopefully
then that's something which can be
passed to others so so have you bought a
lot of property then
you go yes you go yes we have yes we
have and it's it's what you bought tell
me talk us through it it's building so
this is the fourth year in since the
academy yeah and the first year was all
about education
and finding 13 patches which was
ridiculous because we live in cornwall
so ginny's come up from cornwall to your
place today and i've come down from
cleethorpes and
you know it there's a lot of time travel
you don't live in keith obviously you've
got your office there well we've got a
base there which is really important you
know we've got offices there and you
know that's the side that we're
developing and really excited about
coming on to but as far as property goes
in the first year and i still remember
something you said because when you
started you had a guarantor for your
first place yeah yeah but then there was
a couple of slow years wasn't there
before you really got going i believe
where it was about you managing other
and it's been very similar for us yeah
my second year in property i didn't buy
a single thing well there you go we had
we had some highly leveraged property in
cornwall still so we had four single
left
in fact five single lets and that's what
we started with which was producing a
basic what year did you buy those um so
i bought
uh 2008
with the four flats that we've got right
and
1992 i think was that wow so you've been
in property since i was one
yeah
that's why that's what that's what you
are that's what
that's why i'm happy to have you guys
come back and mentor because you've been
in the game for 30 years
five years ago you were not making loads
of money but you still had experience of
being a landlord having tenants you had
a little portfolio
now you've obviously taken things to a
whole new level but those properties
were so highly leveraged at that time
and it was the classic i guess landlords
typical landlord would get sort of one
two or three properties trying to manage
it themselves and you know with no
science behind it
so
we do we continue to do that while we
were on the academy and you know i said
to junior we've got to get into these
hmos so even though we were deal
sourcing because you told me i had to
i'll still hold you to that the cash
flow the cash flow because because
property's slow yeah takes time to even
buy a house so you need if you're
building up your portfolio you need
something now that's going to bring you
in that fast pound definitely so uh the
second year we realized that we had an
hmo but we just weren't renting it as an
hmo in cornwall and
you know
the experience of actually getting that
one compliant and going through and
refurbing it to a to a reasonable level
um down there and that's the one who
cash flows really nicely for us down in
cornwall now but that experience is i
and i say this to mentees all the time
you've got to get out there are all
sorts of ways of making money but just
get started
just get started on one thing and start
watching that so true because you can
get parallel parallel spine paralysis by
analysis can't you really think shall i
do this or this or this all this
absolutely and i think we're classic
cases of that aren't we spend so much
time thinking about it and it all needs
to be
perfect tell me though jenny because
you've bought some amazing houses and we
want to know what they are so what have
you been buying because you've got some
really exciting stuff on here that you
bought so we've just had two that have
that are now up and running in klee
thoughts that were bought with investor
finance two really high-end hmos
six beds six ensuites
really high spec
in fact i think um
the valuer came around actually said it
was one of the best that he'd seen wow
in that area for a long long time and it
is really good yeah it's really
impressive and that's what's that's what
i've loved it's actually seeing the
energy
any of your money in or not no
no
so two big hmos
zero money down
investors finance yeah
how much are they cash flowing between
the two of them
between two of them the portfolio at the
moment is cash flowing between nine and
ten isn't it thousand pounds a month and
you know
the turnover on that is around fifteen
thousand pounds yeah that's part of it
so that's the whole lot isn't it
that's brilliant yeah i mean it's on a
buy refurbished refinance model and you
know that's like i said in our area the
building rigs are really tight and it's
put a lot of investors off but actually
when you actually understand it and
unpick it you know working on commercial
valuations so
the the one i think you were talking
about was the last but one wasn't it
where
we bought it 114 do you know we put in i
think that because refurbs have gone up
i'm sure you'll find yeah
and it's ridiculous the amount they got
but we referred at 83 which
it was a beautiful victorian house
we put that in
um and it refinanced on a commercial
valuation at 275. yeah i think we we we
got out more or less everything by 15
000. yeah and
that's
the day before the valuation the nhs
trust in the local area which is
providing quality housing for overseas
nurses and doctors
you know they signed uh took the whole
property on on a six-month
agreement and they agreed that i think
the rent was three six three three seven
something like that yeah so that just
took it straight off our hands and
obviously the valuer he couldn't you
couldn't argue with that there's three
thousand seven hundred pounds coming
into that
yeah absolutely and we've taken that on
and
the latest one is in an area in klee
thoughts which we know the rental
demands there and
i mean you said about
the business our offices
for me i really needed to get confidence
in the market with the rental demand and
you know it sounds cheesy but you know
we worked well with an hmo manager when
we first started there in year one when
the the um
portfolio was going through now we've
stayed in touch he was a sophisticated
investor he was educated and he's a
hotelier and a serviced accommodation
portfolio and rent to rents and had been
through the education process
and he's the one that we've ended up now
merging the company so we're going to be
buying shares in his company apex pv up
in kleethorpe's
and that provides an end-to-end
hands-free service for investors and i
mean you've had lettings businesses yeah
and they're very very active aren't they
very active yeah and we found that and
you know that's deflected us so it's
it's it's almost a lost leader that we
know back to domination in an area when
you get your signboards up and you know
you have a presence in the area and you
match your social media and yeah
so for us that was a really important
thing to actually get so the last sort
of 12 to 18 months it has been put in
the processes because we manage a few
properties in cornwall which we're
merging all into this one company let me
ask you a question right if you're
making
nine grand a month passive income from
all your properties that's over a
hundred grand a year
why would you not just
retire
chill out
live on a beach
and never do anything ever again work
related why are you around my house
right now why are you coming to the
event still why are you doing mentoring
calls and trying to still dominate areas
then i mean you've quit your jobs you
don't need to work
what's
what's the where's the desire got more
to do got lots more to do i feel like
we've just started really and and for me
now
yeah it's really about building the
wealth establishing the wealth building
the legacy and
and seeing what we actually can achieve
within the next four years and that's
what we've and you've been going about
four or five years
hardcore
yeah it has been full-on we've got
another four years that's the thing when
you've got that you know what in four
years sorry in four years to go
if you're planning on retiring four
years
maybe you might have a portfolio to 20
grand a month for 50 grand a month i
guarantee you will not retire in four
years
well i never said retire the reason i
asked that question because that's what
people ask me all the time people say to
me why'd you
yeah or why don't you even
even if you just systemize the training
business
and get ricky and the team to run it
like why do you continue to works and i
think the thing my thinking is on this
is because
you're not truly happy unless you're
progressing
true for people always think oh i just
want to line a [ __ ] and do nothing but
actually that's boring
so for me it's like i want to be
continually building and doing stuff and
also giving back and helping people and
fulfilling people you know but it's just
people ask me and also people ask me why
do you use other people's money when
you're wealthy and you could use your
own money what would you say to that one
because you don't need to borrow other
people's money now you are at a point
where you could
use your own money but why would you use
the bank's money do you know that that's
the it's about leverage isn't it and do
you know for us going forwards i've got
really big plans i i i had to muzzle
myself when you were talking
i've had this realization that i've done
myself for a long time and actually
burning inside was always this creating
this
and it is the end-to-end hands-free and
to start with i think people say oh
that's you just want to make money all
the step of the way yeah we will make
some money every step of the way but
we'll also help a shed load of people
that will come to grimsby and
cleethorpes without the confidence in
the market and i can show you the
confidence markets because we've got a
95 occupancy rate across our portfolio
in that area so we give them confidence
to put the money back into that area
housing stock in the area improves
the council's happy we work really
closely with the council and they're
very proactive and the housing
enforcement team up there
you know
they love it when people are putting
back quality compliant property and
that's what we want to do and make a
name for and actually
it's like your training business if you
know if you create the entity where it's
working and you can be a focal point in
four years time i just want to be doing
something different i want to set that
one up and keep it moving i don't know
what i'm going to do in four years time
our business partner is a little bit
older do you know and we've just we've
signed head to terms now for four years
time there will be an exit whether we
sell yeah or whether somebody takes over
or buys the shares or whatever then
you'll do the next thing you won't just
relax at home i bet no i don't think we
will and it and for me that's what it's
about it's almost now i've made this
this leap of faith
and i really really want to see how far
i can go or we can go within that four
years and and that's what's really
exciting
because it's something so different to
everything that i've done before i felt
awake samuel because it's been me
banging on to start with oh my god i can
see this and you know bilo rent high and
we've got to start this and
and ginny's come alive and it's it's
awesome because we're partners and also
business partners and there's stresses
and we're also very different you know
we talk about the wealth dynamics that
you showed us what an awesome tool
because you you can work out
who else you need in your team yeah to
actually and i realized no you just
can't dominate on your own you need
other people around you whether you
employ them or whatever
but jenny and i worked out sometimes
there's friction because we're coming
from two different sides we're thinking
about the same problem in two different
ways how often do you spend in in
cleethorpes do you know like well i
haven't very much up until now because
obviously i've been committed um in with
my job in in cornwall so
i haven't spent a massive amount of time
there i've been up a few times um
and it will be more now now i've got
that freedom you own the office in glee
thoughts or do you rent it we're renting
but we've got four conveying at the
moment and one is a three-story office
block ex-council box so they've they've
gone through and made the place amazing
all the tech is in general
so that's conveying at the moment and
we'll take over the ground floor of that
one so we'll own that property through
the business and then the top two floors
we've got planning for
four two bed apartments
so it's first kind of commercial to
residential venture as well and it's
things like that when
yeah i know we laughed about the
dominating but if you put yourself out
as a presence people come to you with
the deals yeah and that's the fantastic
bit at the moment what do you think
about people that say that there's a
housing crisis at the moment and people
like people like us
buying lots of houses pushing prices up
yes we're making loads of money but it's
not ethical
that's a really tough question no no
you know i i don't see the argument in
that because you know you
you're creating value in properties and
doing areas out so these areas in
grimsby cleathorps are really tough
jenny almost quit then on the spot
that's a good point
right selling everything yeah that's it
i haven't thought of that
but but this area's in greenswingly
thoughts that are tough same as anywhere
but we're adding massive value we're
creating combined housing yeah yeah
rents are going up anyway do you know
everything's going up here's what i
would say about that as well what you're
doing by refurbishing finance right
mostly
so you
are buying houses
that are run down that have been run
down for years probably
by turning them into a house you're
actually bringing the price of rent down
and making houses more affordable
because you're bringing new supply onto
the market
and now tenants have got more choice
so you're actually balancing the market
out
so you're not going to quit
[Laughter]
the academy for us was a
for me certainly was a massive
eye-opener to the possibilities within
property and i remember coming jeremy
had gone to a crash course came back and
said i really would like you to come to
a crash course so i came along not
really sure what to expect
and
and this probably sounds a little bit
over the top but i can honestly remember
being completely and utterly
gobsmacked about how amazing it was from
the minute we walked in the door in
three day or two two full days was it at
that time and just thinking this is
mind-blowing and i was so impressed by
you so for me it was it was massively
inspirational and and it was almost uh
yeah we got to do this this is
definitely
an opportunity for us now because we
were starting afresh and looking for for
new things and yeah it was it was
massively
educational inspirational met some
fantastic people
and
started to develop a really really
good base
to sort of develop our property
knowledge from i feel like as well with
the academy i feel like we've improved a
lot over the last four years like i
think now you'll know because you're
still part of the academy the support
and the
the structure and everything i think is
is is better yeah than it was and i
think it was amazing yes but now it's
even better which is good because you do
it would be easy as we grow and as my
brand and my business and my reputation
grows i get more views more followers
it'll be easy for the academy just to
become
like
diluted but i think it's actually got
stronger and better and richer um
another thing i want to ask you guys is
you got started on the academy in 2018.
um
the following year
i got a lot of hate online and you guys
will probably remember press all kinds
of stuff and you guys stood with me
through all that and there was a lot of
people that didn't there was a lot of
people that wanted to distance
themselves all i could say to anybody
that came to us was about our experience
and i continue with that with the
mentors i'm not telling you what to do
i'm giving you my experience and for the
12 months it was exactly what we needed
formatted in the right way at the right
time and you know i've got nothing but
praise for what we received during that
12 months and you know i don't know the
ins and outs of the people that were
there were hating that and there was
there was a lot of publicity about it
but if you bring it back you can only
control what you can
control in your own little environment
yeah and for us
yeah the the money that we put into that
academy was we've now got friends for
life but business associates for life
and you know there are people
from that academy now that we still work
with and you know you've set up
something which
you can take advantage of or not that's
your choice which is the education
massive action bit so from us hand on
heart and that's for anybody listening
you know what we received during that
academy was exactly what we needed
totally but we also made that work as
well by maybe taking the action what
were your like friends family when you
said to them i just registered for the
academy put it on a credit card
and we're
[Laughter]
i didn't know that by the way at the
time but but and i definitely don't
recommend that no and we don't encourage
that but the question is your friends
and family did you have
a positive and negative or a mixed
response when you told them that you
were wanting to step into property in
the way that you were yeah it definitely
wasn't a negative response yeah and i
wouldn't say it was a positive response
either it was it was a very kind of
neutral
response to it and i think probably
giving up my job has been has provoked
the most kind of concern and
and worry from from parents and family
and friends rather than actually getting
into property in the first instance and
going through the education i think that
received a very
yeah very neutral response
i would say
well both your parents are employees
aren't they or have been yeah
yeah and you know
from
my dad who was a policeman through and
through
do you know he retired at 48 on a full
pension and you know
he he doesn't understand that size and
it's a risk
but i also understand why he sees that
as a
risk that now though things have changed
like what worked 40 years ago i.e having
a job having a pension putting money in
the bank buying a house paying off the
mortgage that did work
if you know 50 years ago that was not a
bad strategy now it's a terrible
strategy
so things have changed absolutely and i
think that's why
and because we have started from scratch
that's why we are where we are doing
what we're doing isn't it because things
need to be different in order for us to
be successful and build our wealth yeah
so you've gone from neutral to we've got
two family members now that invest in
our property brilliantly and i love it i
love that but you know i realized how
long i'd been trying to get their
affirmation over the years that what i
was doing was was right
and it was a real real awakening so i've
got two brothers one investing property
um around and um
when they actually came in and jv'd and
we we set the company up and we we did
the property and it ended up coming up
because i was still nervous because you
know things can change
but we've done everything that we could
do for the due diligence
but then
with buy refurbished refinance you are
at the behead of of a valuer and
ultimately the valuer came around and we
created we'd invested in ourselves and
created a valuation pack which will
guide the valuer without slapping them
around the face and saying this is it
exactly and it was seriously it was
almost comical wasn't it because the
valuer turned up i was outside the
property stalling him while ginny was
printed out
and john was turning up behind him
cut a long story short we got what we
needed and you know my brother and my
mum is and you know they were absolutely
tickled pink with it and the biggest
thing as well it's got this garage on
the back of this property victorian
property which is like a small sports
hall
and so we've got planning permission
going through and at the back now to
convert that into flats
but that's the legacy bit and i want to
be able to create some passive income
for my mum
and you know
at this stage of life for her it would
be awesome and so my brother was
stalking me so one of my brothers was
talking to me on social media and
checking out what we're doing
can i come up and have a look at and now
he's involved so
that that was an awesome i think the
only way to win over your skeptical
friends and families to show them your
results i think yes yeah definitely and
i think i think that will come for me
now definitely once
now i've made the jump now i'm in the
business now we're actually starting to
really see the fruits of our labor how's
life changed well tell you what for
three years it has been graff it has
been hard graphed and it but it's one of
those and i think i said to you you wake
up in the morning and you know what
let's bring it let's bring it on and see
what the date comes with and
i think
for us now we do want to start
protecting time and i think you've just
come back from a nice holiday and you
know we've got one booked in in
september and you know
there's we can do that without worrying
about you know where we were before and
certainly
we're going to continue to work hard
we've got the four year plan but it's
freeing us up there's a lot of
travelling we do a lot of travelling for
the choices that we make i think at the
moment we have got we have got a time
ahead of us which is going to be really
intense in terms of grafton being
completely active and and and actually
working very very hard we live in
opposite ends of the country a lot of
the time and that's a shift in the in
our lifestyle at the moment but we kind
of know that we've got a long-term plan
we need to be really careful that we
enjoy things along the way and not get
too
wrapped up in in just
the success of the business we need to
make sure that we enjoy life absolutely
as we go and celebrate successes that's
part of what this one is like time
stamping where you're at well we said
about a tipping point i think earlier on
so in your first year you you were
saying when you started at 8 17 and then
18.
do you know so we've got four properties
conveying at the moment so there's a
pipeline of property and a pipeline of
investors and there's a tipping point
and of course you've got to keep
managing it yeah but it's really
exciting where it's going now so we've
got two bmv flats that are going through
which we picked up at a very nice price
there which we know we can remortgage
again in 12 months time and you know
we'll get that money back out and
there's also a commercial unit on the
back of a four bed hmo which it's sat on
the market because people just don't
understand it uneducated people just
don't understand it so we've got a
really good broker that we work with
they said yeah we'll put that on a
commercial loan and you can refinance
that further down the line and there's
more and more of this happening now
which that's the really exciting thing
for me yeah it's gathering pace isn't it
yeah and i think once we're all once
we're all in it together it will gather
more pace yeah but it's not all about
business you know the vision is to
create a nice big home in cornwall yeah
and
you know we've got now our base up in
our patch as well so
you know that makes you part of the
community and you know
i i went out for a drink one evening and
you know there's people that are
starting to recognize you and you're
that property guy aren't you oh yeah my
aunt's just getting rid of her place and
you know and just
just how it how it works but well you've
done amazing and i'm really um pleased
with your success but also i'm really
grateful for you know coming back into
the community and i always say when you
hit the mountaintops you've got to pull
people up with you and that's exactly
what you're doing so appreciate that
appreciate you and thanks for coming on
the show thank you for having us yeah i
really appreciate it thank you
[Music]
you